rich people will always pay for Speed
and so if you don't have a fast option
or if you look at a Marketplace and
there's lots of slow stuff the easiest
way to appeal to the rich is just do the
same thing in half the time rich people
will want often the same Services as
poor people because they are humans but
the way they want it delivered is going
to be focusing on effort and sacrifice
and time because that is fundamentally
how you deal with rich people they just
want it to be effortless they don't want
to think about it and they will pay you
through the nose to do it because for
them it's not through the nose because
you need to make sure you're selling out
of their Wallet not yours